eine kur wird krankenschwester in new
york eine fahrerin in new mexico und
eine bestatterin in kalifornien sie alle
haben uns mitgenommen in ihren alltag in
den usa wehren corona schauspieler
zeigen wie sie gerade überleben und
liebespaare wie sie versuchen sich den
ganz großen traum doch noch zu erfüllen
das ist micron new york city ist das
epizentrum der kona pandemie in den usa
ich bin wie ich bin eine reisende
krankenschwester und kämpfer gerade in
new york gegen korona seit mehreren
wochen arbeitet die 26 jährige auf einer
intensivstation in manhattan
noch immer gehört die stadt zu den am
schlimmsten von corona betroffenen
regionen der usa
das darf nie damit in ein paar tagen
auch persönlich zurecht kommen muss und
sie jetzt noch nicht nicht bei meiner
familie zu sein so viele patienten
sterben zusehen
das ist eine krasse erfahrung ich bin
seit eineinhalb jahren krankenschwester
und ich habe noch nie so viele patienten
sterben sie
china
wir werden das später wieder treffen
vorher geht es in den westen über 3000
kilometer entfernt in new mexico sieht
das leben ganz anders aus mein name ist
kirsten cuevas und ich habe eine kleine
farm in thum in new mexico auf ihrer
kleinen bio pharm züchten kirsten und
ihr mann schweine und rinder
kaum zu glauben dass corona virus war
für sie etwas positives weil einige
menschen supermärkte meinen wollen ist
die nachfrage nach fleisch und eiern
direkt vom bauern gestiegen
gut für kirsten denn aktuell fallen zwar
die farm us-märkte aus aber sie verkauft
ihre produkte an eine genossenschaft
[Musik]
ich habe die eier da hinten in einer
kühltasche seht ihr die krone hat
unseren alltag schon verändert aber man
muss sich einfach daran gewöhnen aber
das ist okay dadurch dass die
bauernmärkte ausfallen habe ich mehr
zeit mich um den hof zu kümmern
das ist hobby sie bleibt hier die
nächsten wochen drin
wir haben hier einen geburtsstadt in
unserer garage eingerichtet was kerstin
wichtig ist einander unterstützen
ich bringe die farmer hier mit der
genossenschaft zusammen so können auch
sie ihr gemüse verkaufen
wir kommen endlich als gemeinschaft
zusammen und ich denke das ist so
wichtig besonders wegen all dem was
gerade in diesem land passiert es ist so
wichtig sich wieder nachbarschaftlich zu
verhalten
wir müssen aufhören mit hass und
anfangen einander zu helfen das ist das
wichtigste so gut wie kirsten auf ihrer
farm geht es vielen in den usa nicht
denn hier gibt es die meisten corona
toten weltweit
frey ich bin lindsay verengten ich bin
bestatterin in santa monica kalifornien
corona hat lindsay ist berufsleben auf
den kopf gestellt ich bin vorher immer
zu den familien gefahren nach hause ins
krankenhaus
um sie zu treffen und alles zu regeln
das hat sich komplett geändert jetzt
mache ich das übersehe ich musste alles
umwerfen das war hart aber noch härter
ist den familien erklären zu müssen dass
sie ihren geliebten menschen nicht noch
einmal sehen können gegen korona dürfen
sie sich hier nicht mehr verabschieden
lindsay versucht trotzdem ihnen ein
gefühl von näher zu bringen
ich bin jetzt auf dem weg zu einer
familie um die asche ihres angehörigen
zu bringen das ist eine meiner
dienstleistungen
aber das ist ein großer unterschied zur
vor corona zeiten
das ist jetzt das erste mal dass sich
die familie persönlich treffe
wir umarmen uns nicht das ist echt so
anders das nimmt so einen wichtigen teil
meines jobs weg das unterstützen und
auch beerdigungen sind betroffen
die friedhöfe erlauben nicht mehr als
zehn personen gleichzeitig
das bringt die familien dazu ihre
verstorbenen in kühlkammern zu lagern
bis sie eine richtige beerdigung
veranstalten können
das ist ziemlich teuer auch für lindsay
persönlich ist das hart das bricht mir
einfach das herz die ganze sache nimmt
ihr das recht auf eine angemessene
bestattung
das ist nicht der grund warum ich
bestatterin geworden bin
um den menschen in solchen schweren
zeiten etwas abzuschlagen
nur ein paar kilometer weiter südlich an
dieser traumhaften küste in san diego
kämpfen noch mehr mit den auswirkungen
von corona ich bin ein konträres und das
ist meine verlobte franziska franziskas
für ducati hierher ausgewandert
corona hat die usa in einer arbeitslosen
krise gestürzt das hat auch die beiden
hart getroffen
wir sind spazieren es ist samstag und
super wetter die erste bahn hat gestern
aufgemacht es sieht eigentlich aus wie
vergangenen sommer aber nichts ist wie
vergangenen sommer ducati ist eigentlich
marketing manager in einem unternehmen
das sport events organisiert doch sport
events in corona zeiten gibt es nicht
das business des 29 jährigen ist erst
einmal tot
wir sind von einem zehn personen team in
meinem büro und etwa 200 im ganzen land
heruntergestuft worden auf nur noch zwei
beurlaubte angestellte intensiv alle
anderen wurden entlassen
das gehalt ist am absoluten minimum das
leben in san diego wie überall in
kalifornien ist teuer
wir sind auf arbeitslosengeld angewiesen
aktuell bekommt okotie zusätzlich zum
arbeitslosengeld einen scheck über 600
dollar pro woche aus dem hilfspaket der
regierung
klingt erst einmal nicht schlecht aber
die 600 dollar von der regierung gibt es
nur bis ende juli freundin franziska ist
selbstständig auf ihr business wurde von
corona hart getroffen als nicht us
bürgerin hat sie aber keinen anspruch
auf staatliche unterstützung der
christen fürs detail meiner kunden kommt
aus deutschland
und ja durch corona müssten ihr
vorübergehend des unternehmens schließen
ich weiß es auch nicht wie lange wir das
jetzt noch so durchhalten können
gemeinsam versuchen sie irgendwie das
beste aus der situation zu machen und
vor allem viel zeit miteinander zu
verbringen
hier seht ihr unsere art und routine
nach dem essen trinken wir wein und
spielen karten
ich gewinne eigentlich immer mal sehen
was heute passiert das wichtigste für
die beiden sie müssen da gerade nicht
alleine durch zurück in new york bei def
i 12 eineinhalb stunden täglich sieben
tage die woche die meiste zeit muss die
krankenschwester nachts arbeiten auf der
intensivstation im metropolitan hospital
wissen sie das virus kann jeden treffen
dieses virus macht keinen unterschied
heute lebst du morgen stirbst du
trotzdem und gerade deshalb versuchen
darf nie und ihre kolleginnen sich
gegenseitig aufzumuntern und trotzdem
freude an der arbeit zu haben
doch dann trifft sie das virus plötzlich
ganz persönlich ihr vater hat sich
infiziert liegt auf einer
intensivstation in florida und kämpft
und sein leben jetzt nach hause fliegen
keine option nur videoanrufe sind
möglich
ihre kollegen geben ihren dieser zeit
heilt sie sind für sie da vor allem als
sie geburtstag hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das positive während dieser ganzen zeit
sind die freunde die ich gefunden habe
sie sind wie eine familie es ist
wirklich anstrengend aber sie hierzu
haben motiviert mich jeden tag weiter zu
machen
zu wissen dass man diese unterstützung
hat sie wissen wie es ist dass es toll
wir werden später dabei sein wenn dave
nie wieder nach hause zurückkehrt neuer
ort neue sorgen
hallo cherry hill new jersey ich bin
theaterschauspieler und sollte gerade
ein stück in miami fly überspielen aber
mit 19 hat andere pläne
nun liefert anthony pizza aus um sich
über wasser zu halten
alles andere als sein traumjob klar bin
ich traurig dass ich nicht das machen
kann was ich liebe normalerweise reise
ich viel arbeit im theater fernsehen
oder film
das alles wird gerade sehr weit um sich
trotzdem nah zu sein trifft er seine
schauspielkollegin viasuisse über linien
zusammen wie es künftig weitergehen soll
unsere arbeit ist sehr körperlich wir
arbeiten viel mit atem und bewegung
nennt oft sind wir quasi übereinander
und kommen in kontakt mit atem- und
spucke der anderen
das sollte man gerade lieber nicht
machen stattdessen proben sie nun für
ein online theaterstück
als pizzabote kauft anthony auch für
seinen arbeitgeber 1
er ist besorgt weil viele hier nicht
genug auf abstand achten findet er die
glauben dass sie es besser wissen als
ärzte oder wissenschaftler
das hilft nicht
weil er so viel kontakt mit anderen hat
dies infiziert anthony sein auto nun
immer sehr gründlich er sorgt sich nicht
nur um seine eigene zukunft sondern auch
wie es seinem land nach corona geht eine
hochzeit im park in philadelphia
so hatte sich das jordan price niemals
vorgestellt
wir konnten immerhin denselben fahrer
haben nur kurz für die zeremonie in
diesen unsicheren zeiten waren wir uns
in einer sache sicher wir wollten mann
und frau werden
wir haben unserer familie eine woche
vorher bescheid gesagt und wer in der
nähe wohnt konnte komme allen anderen
haben wir fünf stunden vorher einfach
einen zoom link geschickt
so sind viele wenigstens online dabei
während die beiden sich das jawort geben
in einem jahr soll dann die große party
stattfinden
gefeiert haben sie jetzt aber trotzdem
schon ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich
mein eigenes hochzeitsessen vorbereiten
oder mein kleid selbst auf bügeln würde
es sind verrückte zeiten
ich würde es immer wieder machen jetzt
bin ich glücklich verheiratet sogar mit
richtigem hochzeitstag
trotz oder gerade wegen corona es sind
die letzten tage für krankenschwester
darf nie in new york city bevor sie nach
hause darf wird sie selbst einmal
gründlich durchgecheckt wird selbst kurz
zur patientin hättest du mich vor acht
wochen gefragt was ich fühle hätte ich
wahrscheinlich angst gesagt angst weit
weg von meiner familie zu sein
gegen ein unbekanntes virus zu kämpfen
und nicht zu wissen was mich und die
patienten morgen erwartet jetzt acht
wochen später wenn du mir die gleiche
frage stellst würde ich sagen ich bin
okay ich bin stolz ich habe alles für
meine patienten gegeben
ich weiß dass wir nicht jeden retten
konnten aber ich weiß dass ich alles
gegeben habe
das reicht für mich ich habe meine
patienten wie familie behandelt sie
waren auch getrennt von ihrer familie
das zählt für mich am meisten
dann geht es endlich zurück nach hause
nach florida zu ihrer familie und auch
zu ihrem papa
er hat corona gut überstanden ihre
freizeit will sie nun vor allem mit ihm
verbringen